you have to have some kind of crazy
workout regimen you always look perfect
what are you doing even you must take
very good care of yourself I do uh I do
workout but I do a lot of cleanses yeah
me you drinking that drink I just did a
new one at OHS I'm gonna buy like sweet
grass every day I've never I've never
had does anyone like yeah I've never had
it besides like cats yeah it is an
acquired taste is it yeah yeah but if
you don't want to drink it you do it as
an enema
sure or do you do that or yana colonics
that that's I've been to yes that's what
I've been doing so I just want to say
this too and I don't want to brag but
apparently wheatgrass is very hard to
hold you know but my intestines love it
so most people they can hold it for like
30 seconds and I'm I'm thirty minutes
yeah yeah that's I have to say I've been
doing this a long time that's the
weirdest celebrity brag I've ever heard
you gotta figure out how to get that in
the Olympics yeah no I can get it and I
can hold on to that for a long time
particularly wheatgrass wheatgrass okay
I mean I think do you do it you do it
I've never done a colonic in my life
what about an enema no no I have not you
ever ever done that spouses do it for
each other yeah that's not gonna happen
now you'll see you'll meet her
I love her I love my wife she's not
doing that that's not gonna get out ya
know what you can do it I can every
night
what's up like would you give me one
[Applause]
remote that's a remote we could do and
obviously I'd be covered in the you know
particular areas unless you wish
otherwise why'd you say no I don't think
everyone you should gift them with that
yeah saying I could peek yeah could be a
little probably a little curious about
what's going on down there a little kind
of a lot can all of you just leave us
alone
what them all to go do it for you I
don't mind okay we have to talk about
this because I would like to see this
through okay
[Applause]
you